- So wait, you got into TikTok last year?
I need to show the world this.
Here is you doing the
whipped cream challenge.
(audience laughing)
- [Guest] What?
- [Kelly] Missed it.
- [Male Translator] Merry Christmas, wait.
(Kelly, guest, and audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
- [Guest] Look at the bat.
- [Male Translator] And the dog.
- The dog.
The dog is like, "I love this challenge."
Are you-
- [Male Translator] Very happy.
Definitely very happy.
- Are you still into TikTok?
- [Male Translator] I'm
going to get more into it.
I have plans to get into it.
I can't decide what we're going to do
for filming the world,
what our family is doing,
just like everybody else is doing
with their families.
- Yeah.
- We'll see.
- I loved how not one of
you was excellent at it.
(Kelly slapping wrist)
(Kelly laughing)
I mean, it's a weird talent to have.
- It's a mess.
- [Male Translator] It's
a mess, it's a big mess.
It's fun, you should
try it with your kids.
- I know.
I honestly, they would any...
Any way they can inhale
sugar, they'd be into it,
(audience laughing)
so yeah,
I'm going to do it with like broccoli.
It's the broccoli challenge.
(audience laughing)
It's like...
- If I wasn't an actor,
I probably would own a candy store.
- Oh, now my daughter wants,
either she wants to run a
candy store or a bakery.
I'm like, "All right."
- Both.
- Yeah.
I'm like, "I like those
things, it's fine."